[Music]
we're gonna be talking about building
multi-tenancy machine learning
applications with gke and then using sto
to gain visibility into those
applications and our goal is as a
company is to really better understand
the earth so that's what we're going to
be talking about for the next 40 minutes
my name is Tim Kelton and I'm one of the
cofounders of a startup called dukehart
labs and we're going to be showing some
of the machine learning models that
decart labs has built for its customers
and just a warning I guess we're a very
kind of pixel and imagery focused
company so you're gonna see lots of
satellite images and lots of aerial
imagery so I hope that's okay and
that'll keep things exciting then we're
going to talk about how we leverage
Google cloud and the components we use
as specifically Google kubernetes engine
and then we gain a lot of visibility by
using SEO on top of our micro services
and then finally for an exciting finale
my colleague and our head of engineering
Sam Skillman will join me and we'll show
a brief example of running multi-tenancy
workloads
machine learning workloads on there so I
hope you come away with some great ideas
about running multi-tenancy and how sto
can help give you visibility into your
micro services but I also really hope
you come away with some ideas of how
better understanding changes that are
happening on our earth every single day
might actually impact your your
businesses or organizations and gaining
insight into that can can really provide
those insights so who here has heard of
decart labs a few hints okay that's
that's actually kind of awesome
our story is a little different than the
stereotypical Silicon Valley startup
well we do have Silicon Valley VC
funding and we do have
veteran Silicon Valley leadership we're
actually quite and we have offices here
and in New York our headquarters are
actually way up in the mountains of
Santa Fe New Mexico and it's kind of a
weird place for a start-up in one way
but that's because myself and the rest
of the founding team were were
scientists researchers and engineers at
Los Alamos National Laboratory and there
we were actually working on machine
learning and applying that to a range of
real-world problems including remotely
sensing the earth and so the cloud we
don't have a data center we don't even
own a single server so the cloud we
basically couldn't exist without this
infrastructure yeah on any given day our
staff of scientists can can build models
and they can build them over petabytes
and petabytes of data and they can scale
them on thousands of course and that's
all basically because of the cloud and
that that's really why we're here so our
story is a bit of in some ways it's it's
really about sensors and in some ways
we're using we're looking at sensing the
earth but sensors are really at an
inflection point right now it's they're
changing from a world where data was
kind of individually collected or
manually entered to one where it's it's
basically being continuously sourced and
automatically input by sensors they're
getting better and better resolution all
we're seeing better range better data
transmissions of sensors and the costs
are just dramatically decreasing I mean
this is everything from things I use
riding my mountain bike but all the way
up into the satellites and remotely
sensing the earth just not that long ago
almost all satellites were basically
government-funded so it cost you know
hundreds of millions of dollars for a
project and now an engineering lab
student can make a CubeSat and can
launch that up into space or they can
mount a sensor that they've made in a
laboratory to measure things like radio
frequency they can mount that to a drone
or fly it around on a plane
so this world is is changing and it's
basically becoming a continuous we've
gone from these imprint samples to
almost contingent excuse me continuous
measurements and one of the really big
core challenges that we've always had
with satellites and remote sensing of
data is is getting access to the data
sure you could click and download an
image and it was made for you know that
human interaction of that human analyst
but with machine learning that really
has changed we can process and look at
imagery that humans will never ever look
at in the in our lifetimes again because
there's just so much data and the cloud
has been one of the big enablers in the
last few years it was really hard it's
now finally possible to process and have
every single piece of satellite imagery
or aerial imagery or remotely sensing
data and have that available and
basically build that and make it machine
learning ready
and so this imagery that we put into our
platform is is fully global in coverage
and then it crosses many different
spectrums of light behind me that's
showing near IR on a global composite
and then it's across many different
modalities this is sure we have human
visible light but this is something
called synthetic aperture radar it's not
just it's not where the Sun shines off
the earth bounces off the earth and a
camera captures it instead the satellite
emits a radar signal actually down onto
the earth bounces that off and captures
it it's giving us a global height
measurement around the whole world and
then it's through time and often it's
this temporal cadence that provides
maybe the greatest analytical insight
when we're building models behind me as
NASA's modis imagery this is showing
vegetative health that's that really
really bright green and this is showing
a single frame for every day so this is
looking down everywhere in the US every
day and this is 15 years of imagery
that's that's playing behind you
so you're seeing a half billion pixels
in every single frame of that video and
so visibility and accuracy advantage
comes from the ability to combine in
multiple input sources into the models
there's not really one data set that
provides you all the answers to the
really consequential problems and so
these are across spatial spectral and
temporal and it's this fusion of both
internal data sets that we we built as a
company but it's also public data sets
and we have a lot of stuff imagery from
say NASA or European Space Agency
institutions like that it's commercial
data sets and they all have a critical
time in a place context that's really
required to produce accurate models so
right here I would like to just kind of
dive deeper into what I'm talking about
as an example this is Des Moines Iowa
it's kind of a I don't do we have anyone
from Des Moines I don't see anyone okay
I didn't think so but you never know so
this is a combination of urban and
agricultural landscapes we're seeing the
vector data on the right this could be
ground truth locations or maybe it's one
of our customers pieces of
infrastructure that they've wanted to
tag for changes over time and and then
we have on the far left we can show
vegetation and vegetative health and in
the middle you can see that synthetic
aperture radar I was talking about
earlier the really bright pink and white
is higher height objects and the
challenge is making a range of different
sensor outputs from a range of different
agencies like NASA or European Space
Agency make it all uniform and queryable
so they can be used as all all his
inputs for those models and so our
customers and our our team of applied
research scientists solve a pretty broad
range of problems with
with ml and so we every week we bring
nude sensors and new data sites new data
sets in to try and solve those problems
so what are some of those examples of
types of models that we built to extract
them the most data we built this
modeling platform for complex global
systems and now we have around 15
petabytes of data in our archive and
with this full historical time stack
what it does is allow us to go back
through time and track both conditions
and outcomes so we can generalize that
relationship and and then we can use it
to make predictions based on today's
observations and then we can track new
outcomes and we can measure accuracy and
we can basically continuously be
updating these models so this is an
example this is showing construction and
buildings being started and that's
correlated to steel demand this is
another example showing object detection
we've ran we are doing detection on
buildings and we have run this on the
entire state of California as well as
numerous other parts of the of the world
and actually one of our scientists was
just telling me yesterday that last
Friday we were trying to understand
things like hurricanes and maybe how
hurricanes might impact a state like
Florida and in just a few hours they
were able to scale up and basically map
out every single building in the state
of Florida another example is more from
the agriculture side and that is crop
classification in in the center image
you see that all those really bright
colors what we've done is actually feel
segments out different agricultural
fields to be able to identify which
crops are growing is there wheat or
soybeans or barley or some something
else and then we can use that historical
set of data to go back and train through
time and see
how how those models performed in
various seasons you know some years you
might have a drought other years we have
tons of rain and flooding so you need to
be able to compare with known known
truths over time and to give you just an
idea this is a tech conference and we
talked a lot about compute and scale and
things like that
just to kind of quantify what type of
scale some of these models run at you
know in 2015 were just a few month old
company and we made our first
agricultural models and that was looking
at the entire United States and our
production of corn and so to build those
models we processed around 4 quadrillion
pixels of imagery so that's hundreds of
billions of iPhone photos and we wanted
to build a platform that we really
optimized more for data scientists time
we wanted to promote rapid iterations of
models to get the accuracy we were
looking for on that example it took
nearly a thousand iterations in just a
few weeks so you can't get that rapid
cadence of iterations on your models
without being able to scale horizontally
and so our team uses our platform every
day to continuously improve those
products and build improve the scaling
so hopefully that provides you an idea
with a breadth of the types of mo models
that we wanted to be able to run that
was kind of the goal of what we're
trying to build what does our workflow
look like well we start with a discovery
phase we investigate a hypothesis we
look at what types of data sets we have
available maybe what other data set we
could bring in to help help fuse
together and provide insight and then we
build a lot of candidate models off
those data sets we create and evaluate
those over historical or maybe unknown
truth maybe I knew where a location of a
building was or a radio tower or
something like that and then then we
that model starts being evaluated and
tested and finally it goes into
production and then as we get new sensor
in all the time just streaming its
continuously updated and it basically
generates a continuous time series of
analytics so you can use our tools to to
make your own models or our team of data
scientists can actually build them on
your behalf
and so at this point I'd like to do a
really quick demonstration and it's a
demonstration of typing my password this
is a what we did was we took a big
composite this is aerial imagery of the
entire US this is all actually stored we
don't actually store any of this on GC
on PD discs where oh I haven't switched
yet
oh here we go alright try to so one
interesting thing none of this data is
actually stored on PD disks this is all
being served straight off GCS so that
kind of gives you an idea of the speed
of the Google Network and and GCS
storage but this is a a huge map this is
tens of terabytes of imagery so if you
had to zoom in and look for objects
inside of that say football fields and I
needed to look across terabytes and
terabytes of imagery and find every
single football field that would take a
huge amount of time and so what we've
done is we've gridded that huge
composite image into tiny little grids
and then we've built a feature vector
off each of those tiny little 128 by 128
pixel vectors and then we have
similarity search as ranked them and so
what you're seeing is the most similar
objects to the one I just selected and
so I could do this for anything it could
even be the railroad tracks right next
to it and it shows me all the most
similar objects all across that entire
composite so that's a really quick
example of the types of models we're
trying to build so at this point just
talking a little bit more about the GCP
infrastructure that we use we kind of
have two main portions of our
infrastructure that we've we have the
ingestion and that's very large bulk
processing and getting all of that data
machine learning ready is kind of how we
phrase it and then there's our core
api's and those are more of micro
services based and that's where we run
all of our user workloads as well so
let's dive in to a little bit what what
we do on those to get that imagery ready
that's actually one of the biggest
computational jobs we run as a comm
bunny we have to convert NGO register
all of our imagery for accurate
alignment we have to convert it to
standard projections we need to do
things like remove clouds and cloud
shadows these are really pesky problems
that are kind of hard to deal with we
have to adjust for the camera angle of
the sensor the sun's angle how that
might affect what we're seeing back we
have to calibrate the sensors against
themselves and their neighbors and
compensate for degradation at the top of
the atmosphere so our goal is to take 20
years of camera technology which things
have changed a bit in 20 years and to
make those sensor outputs uniform and
queryable and searchable all on the fly
this is a real example of what that
looks like on the left you see a raw
completely uncalibrated uncorrect edema
jury notice the calibration issues the
cloud cover all of that on the right
then as you move right you can see the
corrected versions we also store vector
data an example of vector data would be
maybe outlines of counties it could be
state outline city outlines things like
that another example might might be
statistics in this example it's actually
the Panama Canal if you didn't recognize
that and one thing you might have is
some sort of a test statistical data set
you might say how many ships pass
through this this portion of the image
so this is from architectural
perspective what those large bulk
processing workloads look like on GCP we
source that data and bring that in and
then we we didn't use pub/sub for
breaking all of our work up into
distributed asynchronous tasks and
pub/sub we found has scaled tremendously
we can we can really really hit it quite
hard and these asynchronous tasks
actually fit really nicely into things
like preemptable VMs because each each
piece of work is very very small in unit
and those machines can go away tomorrow
and we'll just keep spinning up new ones
so we
the cost savings that we can get when we
leverage that and one of the first
examples of how we were actually gained
a lot of confidence that that we would
be able to do this type of workload on
the cloud was scaling up and processing
a petabyte of imagery and we were able
to scale that up to around a 30,000 CPU
core job and then run and process a
petabyte of imagery in about 16 hours
and that gave us confidence not just
that we could get tons of course because
we know we can do that almost anywhere
the bigger and harder problems actually
are would the object storage would GCS
be able to scale with that would the
actual network as we kept adding more
and more nodes would that be able to
scale and so we've actually seen close
to high-performance supercomputing
speeds on on the GCS networks so we and
then we have these other datasets they
could be metadata or information about
those raw pixels or what we refer to as
rasters that could be informations about
what bands of light what modalities what
periods in time things like that we have
we use all types of different persistent
databases to store that and then for
error logging tracing things like that
we're not really in that business so
we're happy to try and use a no op
solution so there we use things like
stack drivers tracing error and
monitoring so in terms of our core API s
how do those micro services look we have
around approximately 50 micro services
any given day we have a new pre alpha or
alpha service coming up we have Canaries
that we're trying out and things like
that so it's always a in flux but one of
the core things that the reason we have
micro services and we adopt them is we
have so many different data types it's
actually really handy to be able to pair
the persistent back-end storage with for
each micro service uniquely and then be
able to scale them individually and
kubernetes multi-tenancy policies are
generally set
most of the time on a namespace basis
and we isolate various microservices by
namespace so then we can explicitly
define policies we can explicitly define
how exactly how exactly we want to see
it scale and react to to load we can do
scaling interaction we can control the
interaction that goes through the
control plane so that's actually goes
through our core API is and that those
core API is become kind of the heartbeat
of our system like we really need to
know and get as much visibility into
that our end users those workloads are
also broke out into their own namespaces
those workloads don't have any
interaction with the backend kubernetes
control plane for the most part that's
all going through our centralized API
and that's because at any given user
they might be able to scale jobs to you
know 10,000 cores and that's not that
uncommon for us so we need to really
funnel that information almost as a
proxy so here's how at least I have
thought about multi-tenancy on
kubernetes this is extremely broad
subject we could have a three-day
conference on it and there's an amazing
kubernetes sake working group that I'd
highly recommend if you really want to
dive super deep they have calls every
week but for this let's define
multi-tenancy as a way to provide
isolation for each tenant that could be
a user or an application and a one
extreme that would be the far-left all
of the users are actually in an
enterprise I know we don't trust all our
co-workers but let's let's say semi
trusted I guess and that's because maybe
that organization has some sort of
visibility into the process and
standards and knowledge of the software
that's going on those those nodes you're
not just letting a regular user from the
internet throw code up and start running
in one of your namespaces and often this
paradigm can parallel a lot with what we
see in kind of traditional IT right
where kubernetes you can have almost a
namespace admin that almost can kind of
be
the centralized IT function or how your
gateway in or out at workloads and the
far other extreme would almost would be
more of a platform as a service or a
kubernetes as a service you have
completely untrusted users running
untrusted code and they're having direct
access straight into the kubernetes api
in control plane you might need to do
things like sandbox those workloads you
might need to isolate them on physical
VMs or isolate them by various node
pools you could even need to look at
something like like gee advisor or cotta
containers to get that level of
isolation our platform is more of a
software-as-a-service
so it's it's really kind of an
in-between the user interfaces directly
with our core api's we don't actually
give direct access to any of our
kubernetes control planes and so those
core API is become that funnel or that
proxy where all the traffic and in the
interaction with the cluster is is
coming and so we we need to allow a
range of models to be executed those are
all Python code for on our API currently
and so we want to isolate each of those
workers by by their own namespace so we
can execute them and then have them only
interact with our api's so where does
this tio come in as those core API is
become that central proxy we need to get
as much visibility into that that
affects how the cluster scaling that
affects how the how much money we spend
things like that we really care about so
visibility becomes absolutely critical
and with distributed micro services one
of the biggest challenges is around the
network you've broken applications out
and they can run in many different
locations so getting visibility into
where different services are running and
that inter service communication is
absolutely important to get metrics and
control and I would imagine probably a
lot of people in there's references and
some of the talks already are familiar
with this tio it's an open source
platform
Google and a number of others have
contributed it gives us load-balancing
for HTTP and G RPC traffic you get
fine-grained control of traffic and
routing retries things like failover
fault injection pluggable policies
automatic metrics logs traces things
like that it in a way it kind of sounds
a bit like magic but in the practical
way it's actually quite a bit simpler
this is a diagram of the actual
components there and the really the one
of the keys of Sto is the Envoy proxy
instead of adding client libraries and
adding a client layer library for every
single service if I have a node app I
need instrumentation libraries if I have
Python I need that so if you even have
something like we have rust maybe you
need instrumentation libraries for all
of those that Envoy proxy instead gets
deployed into your existing code this
could be a Python server it could be a
tomcat server it could be anything like
that and so all the traffic now goes
through that proxy and the proxy
automatically talks back to the pilot
component and the pilot tells it where
every single service is where load
balancing is if if there's any routing
rules that are in effect and then the
mixer is where all of the telemetry and
information starts to come in
that's where there's a pluggable logs
layer where all your logs can get sucked
in up it could go into something like
Prometheus in our case we'll use things
more like stack driver and then finally
you have things like like MPLS for
service to service encryption so if
you're building a platform there's
there's some additional benefits to
consider maybe you might be thinking
about ingress or egress you might say
I'll allow everything at start Google
API is calm to flow out into the world
but I'm not going to actually allow
other sets of traffic you can put that
type of rule there maybe you would like
to do you're getting a lot of five
hundreds and
for every 500 you think it might be a
network blip you might want to do
automatic I might want to retry it three
times before I actually give it return
back a 500 maybe you'd like to do rate
limiting your auth server might be hit
five times a second that might be great
but if it gets hit 50,000 times a second
from one pod well I usually would call
that a DDoS so that type of thing is is
what we try and get out of Sto so here's
a diagram of what things look like
afterwards and overall it's actually not
that different that's actually really
awesome
you're not rewriting that code just to
get that network reliability and that
visibility between each of your services
we're now injecting the sidecar in with
each of those workloads envoy reports
all traffic telemetry straight up into
the sto mixer and provides visibility
into each service who's calling the
service the service to service
automations overall we gain amazing
insights into our core api's that we
actually did not have before
so so with that we would like to do a
quick demonstration of some of the
multi-tenancy workloads and we will do a
quick switch cool okay so I'm Sam scale
and I head up the engineering team at
Descartes lab so this Tim was mentioning
we've got a lot of different workloads
going on from the simple to the very
complex so I'm gonna show a bit of that
right now so if I go to this little
simple application here this is gonna
use our asynchronous task runner to
essentially say hello world
what we do here is we define some
function it's gonna end up posting a
message to some web hook on slack which
if the internet keeps working I'll start
to see notifications on my desktop I go
ahead and create that that function give
it a name give it some docker image that
how much memory it's going to need this
is kind of similar to like a cloud
function like functionality serverless
application and I'm just going to run
this and do that and I can monitor
what's going on through this interface
here so we see that there's 10 pending
messages here so as that goes out within
kubernetes that is now finding
appropriate resources to place those
workloads I spin up those containers and
you can see we're starting to get slack
messages saying hello 1 hello - so
that's all seeming to work we can do
something like we can attach a web hook
to that task where I post a message
saying like what's next and eventually
this would come in we see that there's
one pending message there while that's
running we can look in here look at logs
for what happened to those messages we
could do something like this and you
know that was the log from one of those
that Python function this is just
showing you the very basic
functionalities there I think let's see
I think the hello next is not quite come
in yet but you know we don't we don't
make any money off of saying hello world
we spend most of our time running very
large machine learning workloads at
scale to give you an idea of this like I
had an idea
I guess it was probably like a few days
ago where you know you see some like
really cool stuff like taking a Karass
model that takes the style of one image
and applies it to a set of other images
so I was like okay that would be pretty
cool if we could pull this off during
the demo so we'll see if we can do it so
I essentially just copy and pasted this
this whole workflow here from Charis I
and modified it a bit so that what's
gonna happen is let's see I'm gonna take
Sentinel to imagery which is from the
European Space Agency it revisits the
same place on earth every five days or
so I create a composite from that and
and you know run this this large you
know neural net transfer of one style to
another the details you know would take
again much longer than we have left so
what I've done is I've already actually
started running some of those while I
was sitting in the chair right here but
what you can see happening on the back
end is that this has taken a like taken
our kind of internal namespace for each
individual user and started scaling up
the the workload here so if I get a new
fresh look on here this is climbing up
this is to 200 cores at the moment this
was down at so this started at at 107
about six minutes ago and as the the
system responds to increase load two
more tasks running needing to be run it
continues to scale that up in a way that
doesn't just send a DDoS attack to our
internal services so it kind of
gradually increases load over time we'll
come back to this in a second let's see
so a lot of these ones were quick ones
but then what this has done is then
taken that Sentinel 2 imagery downloaded
it extracted the the style actually from
starry night it's like kind of the
canonical version to take style from and
apply it to elsewhere
it's then created a new data set in our
system as part of our platform sits
right next to the rest of our our
satellite imagery of the remotely sensed
data and started registering data to it
so this is this Sentinel to transfer
live it looks like we've gotten six
scenes a sigh acquired so far if I try
to open this up let's see if we can find
it it might take a little while so the
good thing is I've got some backup here
where if you let this run for about
another ten minutes you'll start to see
the effect so if we zoom out here this
is the United States this is kind of
California over here it looks quite neat
over in Africa and so if we zoom in here
we can start to see the kind of swirly
patterns that you get out of a starry
night painting and so this took
something like two or three thousand
cores it'll eventually scale up to maybe
twenty minutes or so and that's all
running within my kubernetes namespace
that is dedicated just to my user so
that this doesn't impact other users
running on the system we use all the
auto scaling abilities within Google
container engine to just handle whatever
increased load we have alongside of that
these are hitting our internal API isn't
at an increasingly high load when it's
calling out to get those raster's of
sentinal to imagery so those are also in
turn scaling up as the load scales up
itself last night which was quite fun I
took a different dataset which was the
National in agriculture imagery program
does a high-resolution collection over
the United States roughly every year we
might have to get a root there we go so
this is kind of the input data they went
into this one and if I look at what
happens to that we can zoom in here on
AT&T Park but this this also took about
ten minutes or so but scaling up to a
thousand or two thousand V CPUs let's
see how our workload is going here we're
starting to scale up only to 50 but
that's not too bad
yeah so it's starting to process let's
see if we can get lucky and find one
it's just been live there we go so this
was processed we can take a look at it
and say take a look at this and you can
see that it was acquired this is all UTC
time so 117 Pacific so that's kind of
one of the examples of meshing a whole
lot of things together our internal data
catalog that is as Tim mentioned over 10
petabytes of input data all being able
to run custom machine learning models in
this case using tensorflow combined with
Kerris to do a fairly kind of useless
from a business perspective but
interesting from a compute perspective
application all within the the same
system but named spaced out and being
able to track that using all the kind of
metrics that you can collect through sto
and and all the other tools so I think
that's about it for that you can see
here actually I can scale this up real
quick
so you can see that this is just
processing like 3,600 messages there's a
bunch that don't have any imagery like
over the ocean this is currently up to
47 concurrent workers each of those
workers have I think 16 cores and so
that's starting to be a real computation
there so that's it for that
should I just transfer over to the yeah
looks like we already have our last
slide so with that that's most of what
we had to show but some of you might be
saying hey I have a use case I don't
want to go download petabytes and
petabytes of data I know how to build mo
models well for that we actually have a
platform that we offer and and you could
get started right away if you have
visibility into Python additionally we
have so we have Doc's there and how to
contact us and stuff the earlier example
I showed search is available at search
it to cart labs you could look for other
things besides
railroad railroads and baseball fields
or football fields and then finally if
any of you are interested in working on
this type of stuff we're always looking
for more brilliant people so with that
I'd like to thank you
you
[Music]